[Music]
happy holidays everyone it's almost New
Year's as I'm posting this and we
finally have a confirm premiere date for
Young Justice season 3 so I'll explain
what's going on with that because there
are 26 episodes and there's a big
question about how they're gonna drop
all the episodes so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get everything
I do flash ring giveaway every week I'll
explain that at the end of the video but
the reason why everybody's going crazy
this morning is is because the executive
producer Gregg we spent confirmed that
they'd be premiering during the fourth
quarter which narrows it down to October
to December of next year which means
that by this time next year we'll be
watching new Young Justice episodes now
they also talked a little bit about the
new characters so I'll include that in a
second but I know you're all asking like
how are they gonna drop the episodes is
it gonna be Netflix style and they'll
all be dropped at once like all 26
episodes or are they gonna air episodes
one per week like they did when it was
on television if you've been watching
any of the new comic book TV shows that
have been premiering on streaming
services like Hulu or even like Game of
Thrones on HBO now they'll air episodes
one week at a time so the way they
produce animation is a little bit
different from the way they produce
live-action television series Warner
Brothers has really deep pockets they
could choose to do whatever they want
but the reason why I think they're going
to air episodes one week at a time is
because they want to incentivize people
to pay for their streaming service if
they drop the entire season of 26
episodes all at once what would happen
people that just want Young Justice
season 3 would sign up for like the
trial subscription like the free 30 days
that you typically get with streaming
services binge all 26 episodes then
cancel their subscription it wouldn't
hurt any money off of those
subscriptions so they basically take
that monthly fee that you're paying and
use it to make more episodes so Young
Justice season 4 is gonna be paid for by
the people that subscribe to watch
season 3 like when the producer said
that if you want to see season four you
have to support the show the only way to
do that now is to get that DC streaming
service whenever it drops but it's not
like you're just paying for Young
Justice you'll be paying for Titans and
other TV series they roll out so
hopefully that explains the economics of
it a little bit but here's the creators
talking about the new characters that
are joining the team during season three
in the new season there is gonna be a
time a bit of a time jump can't reveal
right now how long it is but in
following keeping with the tradition of
our previous seasons there will be some
some time that has passed we showed
three new characters who are members of
the team spoiler arrow ad and thirteen
and we showed a lineup of characters who
are still with the team they're all a
little bit older a little bit more
experienced a little bit wiser as we
explored a lot of themes in our first
season of genetic experimentation with
the creation of a Superboy visage
genetic experimentation to create a
super power bean could become a weapon
our second season we had aliens coming
from out of space kind of doing pretty
much the same thing and so as we've
already kind of revealed about our third
season metahuman trafficking be the
issue for our heroes to deal with that
is the next next logical step in this
story from our first two seasons they're
definitely new members to the team
roster in season 3 I'm not saying
they're the only new members you know
the light is always our big bad and
Andale Savage they're all partners in
the light but vandals sort of the de
facto leader so vandal is kind of always
our big bad thank you fans thank you
thank you thank you that's what I want
to say to you guys because we would not
be back doing this and Phil Brandon
myself all the voice actors all the
Kru new crew old crew new actors old
actors we're all so psyched to be back
during season so a couple big things
confirmed they're Vandal Savage in the
light are still the big bads of season 3
metahuman trafficking when he's talking
about that remember what was happening
in the Deadpool movie Ajax had that
Weapon X offshoot program where he was
creating metahumans for the black market
just selling them to the highest bidder
warlords all over the earth
so metahuman trafficking human
trafficking that's what they'll be
dealing with in Young Justice season 3
when they call the title outsiders
that's obviously a reference to Batman
and the outsiders team so they're gonna
be working out a lot of underground
things that the normal Justice League
wouldn't be able to spend their time
doing which is why they're called The
Outsiders they handle the things outside
of the purview of the Justice League
you'll be really happy to know that
because it's not on Cartoon Network
anymore it's on the streaming service
there are no broadcast standards that
they have to meet the stories that they
tell will grow up a little bit in the
way that the characters themselves have
grown up in the last couple of years
when they talk about spoiler that's
obviously Stephanie Brown if you
remember she actually had a very brief
appearance during season two when she
had been kidnapped from Bludhaven and
they had to rescue her because they were
trying to isolate humans with the
meta-gene so it was part of this whole
subplot that sounds like they're gonna
continue with this metahuman trafficking
during season 3 I assume it would
interest you to know that in this lab we
are attempting to isolate the meta-gene
by stimulating potentially dormant
powers and average humans but Lagaan
already has powers he is Atlantean
hardly an average human ah but his
powers are based on training in sorcery
beyond that he is an average Atlantean
is he not
now in this lab we study humans with
active meta genes and how they respond
to various levels of stress the goal is
to learn if their abilities can be
extracted or duplicated I see you seek
to weaponize the meta-gene
13 is just tracy 13 she's a magic based
character that they're introducing yet
obviously you know about era wet but
pretty much every other character from
season 1 and season 2 is coming back
they haven't confirmed what's going on
with Wally but remember they had this
big thing about the Speed Force not
existing in the universe that they were
in during seasons one in season two I
think it's just because they haven't
discovered it yet so eventually they'll
get to that too but they might save that
for end of season three or season four
stuff but hopefully that explains a
little bit about where the story picks
up and who the villains are going to be
what the new characters are and you know
what it's gonna feel like in terms of
season 1 and season 2 just a little more
hardcore more adult themes and obviously
dropping sometime between October and
December next year what's gonna happen
next is I have a new Titans video to
post in a couple hours they confirmed a
new character while I was making this
Young Justice video and it sounds like
it's actually gonna be Trigon that's
right they're gonna do Trigon in season
1 of Titans congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Mateo beep please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there was a new round in
this video I'll just name a winner when
I post that Titans video later today so
that should be up in a couple hours so
get hype you can click here for brand
new flash and learning about Batman
Beyond coming back into the TV universe
and click here for all my Wally West
Titans Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight